brother in the neighborhood of geduwai
he's on a campaign to win hearts and
minds senegal's opposition accuses sal
of embezzling billions of dollars in
public funds for the president but he
says he's not here to rob people but to
help them
in politics being the president's
brother is good marketing but as you can
imagine it's also inconvenient because i
am accused of all sorts of things with
the recent discovery of oil and natural
gas the economy is booming but only for
the rich says shekinjai who accuses the
president of leaving the poor behind
[Applause]
life is very difficult for us at the
moment people are going hungry we can't
buy as much as we could before
everything from rice to oil food is
unaffordable it has to stop we're tired
of this
and i was among the thousands of people
who took to the streets in june they
were protesting against the rising cost
of living and a decision by the
constitutional court to reject a list of
opposition candidates for the
parliamentary elections opposition
leader us mansonko accuses president sal
of clamping down on dissent and using
the justice system to eliminate rivals
these elections are rigged when we see
in a democracy a president and the
constitutional court conspires to get
rid of the main opposition candidate for
me it feels like this is a parody of an
election
with the absence of many well-known
opposition faces enjay says none of the
candidates is a good fit for him
these parliamentary elections were
supposed to take place in 2020 but they
were delayed twice once because the
government didn't have enough money to
organize these elections and the second
time because of the covet 19 pandemic
now that they're taking place it's
become less about electing new members
of parliament more about
a test of popularity for president mike
sal
his brother is running on the slogan
united we can achieve victory
leaving enjoy wondering
what will victory mean and who will be
left behind nicholas hawk al-jazeera
gajuwai senegal